hello and welcome to a new day of
exciting chess in this fascinating
matchup between Hikaru Nakamura and
Magnus Carlsen the world champion now
yesterday Magnus was dominant beating
Hikaru free nil but it's a new day today
and more to fight for let's remember it
could be a four-game match but it's if
you get to three points then you win
basically says out of four games two and
a half wins as well and well very
exciting and this game was probably the
deciding gamers the first game of the
day and let's dive straight into the
action so he karo had the white pieces
and it started out with an evil ruler
PES but he karu now meeting the berlin
opening which is Knight to f6 one of the
most solid ways of black to play and I
think every top Grandmaster every Elite
Grandmaster at least has this move in
their repertoire now because it's
supposed to be a good way to get a an
even game safely and now D free and this
is one of the more aggressive moves
because it actually keeps a lot of
pieces on the board the main line is
where white castles and after a forced
sequence of moves we get the famous
Berlin ending and this is you know
Queens off boo I'm gonna be about equal
let's just put it that way I wouldn't be
my cup of tea and Hikaru been an
aggressive player not wanting to take
Magnus into than ending plays be free
Magnus develops Bishop c5 and now Bishop
takes c6 and this basically fixes the
pawn structure from an early stage
meaning that both sides have easier
plans
it should be noted that naka played see
free in a previous encounter against
Magnus Carlsen and now this is a case
where black should take away from the
center because the bishop can develop
quickly and the queen is
this open file in the center white
castle's
and now Bishop g4 a very nice pin on
that night it gets very exciting now
this is a very standard approach that
white now plays h3 and when your
opponent moves the piece into what I say
your half of the board it's often a good
idea to give that piece a kick give it a
little boot move your little H pawn up
let's ask it the question where are you
going son
where are you going and now the bishop
keeps the pin and drops back to h5 and
Hikaru plays a very brave move you've
been a very brave player g4 now this is
a brave move because you're moving the
pawns in front your king and the pawns
in front your king and your bodyguards
they're like keep your King safe and
cozy if you start telling your
bodyguards go on you can you can nip off
go and have a meal go down the pub and
then you and an assassin comes lot well
it's not good news is it so in this case
very risky but the idea is if the bishop
goes backwards we force the bishop to a
bad square and we've moved out of a pin
so we can simply take on e5 so this
forces Magnus to sacrifice are also very
bullet brave play from Magnus as well
and he continues with Knight takes e4
pawn takes g4 Bishop to g4 and Magnus
has two pawns for the piece so he's
behind a material but he's banking on
this extremely strong pin there the
knight can't move because the Queen will
drop and black can try to increase the
pressure with such moves as f5 opening
up the position or even swinging the
Queen around towards the attack
so Hikaru develops and asked the bishop
on c5 a question and now I think this is
Magnus is very crafty preparation he
plays the first new move and the first
new move is Bishop to e7 now previously
Bishop to d6 has been played but after
King to h1 f5 and
rook g1 White was able to get a
perfectly good probably advantageous
game but there are some very small
subtleties with this Bishop being on
this square as we're going to see it
means the Queen has more access to come
to d6 and around the angles which could
be quite useful and the bishop also has
a bit more control over the King sight
so very exciting position so far has
Magnus got enough compensation for the
sacrifice piece and here king h1 plate
actually King g2 would have been better
but Hikaru
maybe knows his previous game where King
h1 was played and now Magnus strikes out
with f5 attacking and trying to open up
lines when you're attacking in chess
you're attacking your opponent's king
the more lines you can open up towards
your opponent's king the better and
black is also trying to get a rook along
that fr therefore increasing the
pressure on f3 and one more thing if
this pawn has ever taken now that the
bishop is out of the way unlike this
variation that had happened before white
has to face Queen d5 which is another
option black now has so rook g1 plate
and Magnus now supports the bishop on
that square with h5 another aggressive
move and here Knight c3 acara developing
and Magnus plays f4 and around here it
looks to me that well Magnus is properly
doing quite well because he's pushing
the white pieces backwards and this pin
is incredibly hard to break
how does white ever get out of this pin
now you can imagine this sacrifice on g4
it works a lot better when White has
lost his light square bishop because in
these types of positions if white was
able to go Bishop e2 the pin would be
non-existent and he coral be winning
easily so it's a little pointer to
remember if you want to try to be a
Magnus Carlsen and sacrifice a piece you
might just look like a
because you've got it in the wrong
position so don't look like a Wally be a
magnus carlsen my voice of the day not
easy to do I wasn't it like a Wally when
I try to be Magnus and now g5 so these
pawns are coming storming down the board
but they issued that Hikaru has it's
very hard for him to move he plays
Knight to be one the night is gonna try
to come to d2 to support the night when
they're free but this takes quite a lot
of time Bishop c5 and now Bishop C free
and Bishop takes f2 so here we see
Carson grabbing that 3rd pawn Knight on
b d2 white doesn't even bother that
saving his material he just develops and
now another good move by Magnus Queen d7
in position like this is more important
just to develop to attack get the King
Castle bring the rook over support your
position they grab the material had the
greedy Bishop takes g1 being played then
white will be able to play Queen takes
g1 & next move Knight takes e5 and all
of a sudden White's pieces jump out of
the jack and box and come to life
so Queen e7 and now we have Queen to f1
removing the Queen from the pin and only
now Bishop takes g1 so black has gained
a useful tempo by placing the Queen here
Queen takes G 1 and now Bishop takes F
free and g4 here they come it reminds me
of the game space invaders
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo they're coming down the
board just like space invaders trying to
steam roller the white pieces out of the
way right towards White's King so white
must come forwards Knight takes e5 and
it's just a matter or whether these
pawns are incredibly strong and also the
Queen can join in the attack
first of all rook g8 to stop Knight g6
another piece supporting those pawns
route to f1 and now Queen to g5 here
they come
here's Johnny and now well Queen 2d for
threatening to counter-attack with Queen
d7 and Queen to f7 checkmate in actual
facts it would have been a lot safer and
in hindsight better to have played Queen
to h2 trying to cover the black queen
from intruding into the position and
after g-free tried to blockade on the
light squares with Queen to g2 because
now White has control of these squares
and is actually pretty safe I don't know
what's going on here
it's a crazy complex position that any
result would be possible in the game
Hikaru now is ready to pounce
but it's Magnus's move first Queen to h4
check King to g1 Queen to g3 check King
to h1 and here typical Magnus Carlsen
there is a reason he's well champion and
if you're a junior out there you can
learn a lot by what Magnus Carlsen now
does even though it might not work out
in the game what he does now is the best
way to improve you've got to take risks
rather than taking a perpetual check
which should be a good result with the
black pieces first game of the day and
maybe even you could say hindsight lures
decides this the wise thing to do
considering Magnus did not have hardly
any time left
Magnus plays for the win now the reason
I say that's a good thing to remember so
many juniors take draws you don't learn
anything the first lesson I got was
always play for the win you'll learn a
lot more if you lose those games then
you will if you draw and it will improve
your stamina and your fear factor you'll
just you know train yourself to always
go for the win that's what well
champions do and he checks one more time
and now plays g3 now this is actually
the wrong way to do it he should have
played rook to d8 with an amazing
concept in mind this is stopping the
Queen coming here and he was probably
afraid of Queen to c4 but in this
position
with Queen to c4 threatening the rook on
this square here can anyone see the
amazing move that is possible what
amazing move is possible in this
position anyone see it it's simply
astonishing rook to d5 and this blocks
the Queen from coming into the position
and it gains Magnus that extra tempo to
attack quite a stunning sacrifice and
the point after pawn takes d5 yes
Magnus is two pieces down but he now has
that tempo and he can use it to go f3
threatening Queen to g2 checkmate and
after something like rook F to G free
and those pawns will win the day this is
very hard to calculate but this is the
win that Magnus missed instead he goes G
free and now he can replace the very
clever
Knight to f3 all of a sudden there's no
checkmate ideas because the night covers
h2 and after the move g2 Hikaru plays
rook e1 and this position is now very
very unclear Hikaru is ready to
counter-attack and Magnus now makes the
last blunder he plays Queen takes F free
now he should have tried b6 because this
gives Magnus the opportunity to play C 5
at some moment and we're gonna see why
the move c5 is quite important for
Magnus after Queen takes f3 it's now he
car is time to have a bit of fun we
can't let our opponent have all the fun
you know we wouldn't play chess for that
reason would we no no no so the Queen
slips in with a check and the black King
is just so bare this is the problem
Magnus has Magnus also doesn't have any
threats now white is covering all of his
attacking ideas and in this case the
combination of Queen and Bishop to
pieces attacking the black king is going
to be pretty deadly
and normally free pieces create
checkmate but two pieces against an real
empty King and when one of those pieces
of the Queen can often be enough King d8
Queen f6 check King e8 and now bringing
the bishop into the game Bishop b4
threatening Queen e7 checkmate now had
Magnus had a pawn on b6 he could have
played c5 but in this position c5 has
just met by Bishop takes c5 he tries it
Bishop takes c5 thinking the King might
have an extra escape Square but after
King d7 Queen to f7 check well it's now
force check mate and Magnus resigns
really distraught and this was an
amazing game remember to like and
subscribe
by the way to the channel HS comm
channel but can you see the checkmate
here I will say if King c6 can you see
how to checkmate a nice little challenge
for you he karu at about 8 minutes in
this position to find it so give
yourself at least 5 minutes see if you
can work out how to force check me and
the news of the day after this game is
that there were three more draws meaning
Hikaru has won today he's won the
account sir leveling the match at one
win for Magnus yes they won it for he
carry today going into the last day
tomorrow make sure you tune into that
it's gonna be brilliant there's a little
bit of rivalry going on between these
two as they're all resist but with
Hikaru doing so well streaming he's
become an absolute legend and a very
followed person tens of thousands of
people watching Magnus had a little a
little bit of complaints about that as
you can read online I don't know where
you stand on that you know it's good to
have a bit of rivalry that's what we
want we want a bit of banter
you know if everyone's nice to each
other all the time it's rather boring so
good on Magnus with a little bit of a
dig it adds drama and but if he loses it
could be one of the first times Hikaru
ever manages to beat Magnus in a match I
can't remember him doing
anytime previously so tomorrow key key
game this is the game that really broke
Magnus and made hikari win today
exciting exciting stuff I'll see you
later do remember to Like subscribe and
take care of yourselves